elle fait partie de ces jeunes voisins
qui viennent goûter chaque année la vie
à la française marguerita une étudiante
italienne conquise par la richesse
culturelle de notre pays
il ya beaucoup de services en france
j'ai payante beaucoup de vie étudiante
comme par exemple faire du sport tissu
sur des campus est complètement gratuit
après on a beaucoup de réduction pour
aller au théâtre pour les musées
c'est en septembre que l'étudiante pose
ses valises à dijon marguerite a rejoint
l'université pour terminer son master de
philosophie un sou dans le ville
je fais du mal à suivre les cours parce
qu'il prend des notes sur un mécanisme à
la preuve n'est pas tout
epito mais maintenant ça va j'ai messier
me tuer
donc on peut y aller
des cours des amis l'esprit campus
erasmus c'est pour l'italienne une
aventure intense une bulle d'air frais
le 3
je suis très reconnaissant versez les
wsop
pour moi avoir donné cette possibilité
parce que faire des études à l'étranger
c'est possible même d'ailleurs données
changent et heureusement mais avec une
chaîne gérard smooth et sixième plus
facile on a notre bourse qui nous aident
payer le logement à vivre à l'étranger
et
même tous les démarches à faire pour
l'inscription conclut simplifiée et
l'étudiante avide de liberté ne compte
pas s'arrêter là
l'an prochain il souhaite rejoindre le
canada pour avoir d'autres images plein
la tête